la frontière autrichienne une barrière
infranchissable il ya quelques jours
encore pour ces centaines de migrants
aujourd'hui ce n'est qu'une étape de
plus dans leur l'empéri leur marche la
veille sur l'autoroute gigantesque
pied-de-nez aux autorités n'aura pas été
vaine l'autriche leur a finalement
ouvert la porte
la hongrie les a laissé passer les cinq
you very much olza olemps aida al talhi
a du mal à réaliser qu'elle approche de
son but
les nombreux jours son sommeil passé
avec sa famille sur la route rendent
pour elle le moment irréel mecs ehlinger
râpé 1 fm jeudi sentiments partagés dit
elle je suis heureuse et triste à la
fois
wright kaddour lui ne boude pas son
plaisir
je me sens tellement bien je viens
d'appeler ma famille en série pour leur
dire que je vient enfin d'arriver comme
les autres migrants
après avoir traversé à pied la frontière
autrichienne
il est dirigé vers des autocars
direction vienne l'aude ordres des
policiers
les femmes et les enfants sont
prioritaires objectif surtout ne pas
séparer les familles
saks départ d'autres s'accompagne de
celle de pagaille de bousculade
tout le monde est pressé de partir à
vienne et personne ne va et si derrière
yens des applaudissements retentissent
chaque fois qu'un train entre en gare
rempli de migrants un accueil chaleureux
à cent lieues de ce qu'ils ont vécu
jusqu'ici le terminus est devenue une
ruche bourdonnante où s'activent les
bénévoles
il offre de l'eau de la nourriture le
café du réconfort chacun mû par la
volonté de présenter à ces exilés un
autre visage de l'europe
je pense que tout le monde doit faire
quelque chose que les politiques ne font
pas grand chose et je j'estime que c'est
pas normal qu autant de gens fuient leur
pays que personne ne s'y intéresse
roland lassnig lui est venue à la gare
avec sa femme et ses enfants dans son
sac
des vêtements des chaussures et les ours
en peluche de ses filles
chacun a fait sa part je ne pouvais pas
rester devant ma télé à bien faire dit
il j'avais besoin de venir aider dit
même si ce n'est pas grand chose
une main tendue un geste simple mais qui
veut dire beaucoup pour ces gens souvent
traités depuis le début de leur périple
comme des indésirables comme des
marchandises
ici jean françois bélanger atouts canada
vienne en autriche